foreign
Denver hi Beth welcome to the Ramsey
Show
you too what's up Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas well I am calling to for y'all
to settle the score and my husband and I
are not necessarily having an argument
but we are having a debate about whether
he should buy a new truck or not you are
the most kind we're not having an
argument we're having a debate we're
just having a debate well well said well
that's nice
but
well I do think he's going to lose but
um we have walked through the baby steps
and we're on set four five and six and
so he wants to buy a new truck and I
don't think what is your net worth
oh
our income is no 400 I don't know our
next income is 400. okay how much do you
have in your mutual funds in in
retirement do you think
um about a hundred okay what's your home
worth
um it's worth 550 a roundabout but we
still have 180 left to pay on it okay do
you own anything else of substance of
large value
no we just own a couple cars okay so if
we had 400 on your house plus 100 you
have a half a million dollar net worth
at roughly okay roughly yeah and you
make 400 000 a year so you're just now
getting to Baby Steps four five and six
you haven't been there long yes we've we
haven't been there very long have you
done and you haven't made 400 000 very
long
um no okay so uh it's a little bit early
to buy a new truck I we recommend at
Ramsey and have for 30 years not to buy
a brand new vehicle unless you have at
least a one million dollar net worth
you're going to be there fairly soon but
you're not going to be there right now
so you win the argument
well thanks assuming assuming I actually
hold the referee's whistle which I'm not
positive I do here but
um assuming you do I'll call him out of
bounds now I will say bye here's the
thing a brand new vehicle goes down in
value it loses 70 percent of its value
in the first four years you cannot
afford to take that big a hit until you
have a substantial amount of money and
then you can afford to lose that much
money and have a nice car but um when
you buy a 50 000 car it's going to be
worth 70 percent of that what 15 000
bucks and about an eye blink when you
buy a hundred thousand dollar car it's
gonna be worth thirty thousand so fast
it will make you throw up a little in
the back of your mouth it's ridiculous
but you can afford that if you've got
two million dollars
I mean you can lose seventy thousand
dollars over three years if you got two
million bucks in order to drive a nice
car and you make 400 Grand you can
afford it that's okay but no I would not
buy a new car in your situation
I think so you think the only time is
after you have that nothing you have a
one million dollar net worth
okay and then all of your vehicles
things with motors and wheels added
together should never add up to more
than half your annual income
so unless he's buying a Ferrari he's
probably okay you set a truck so
you know well you can get 120 000 truck
but um
you know but uh yeah we want to keep
your vehicles under 200 Grand all of
them added together
uh after you have a net worth of a
million dollars this is the Ramsey Show